M
JEB BUSH SAID DONALD TRUMP
A CHAOSRELL, TRUMP LIVP
TO THE
CHOOSING TO DEFIR
ENTIRE INC
AMERICA'S
LRIDOCIIRNREAREDEAHA GCL I W RRE
NTDOST  AEGRGPRIOONSARFMITYSIT I
SECEBUFN CEESRONSON ANTEDITE THL
SIAN ILY
Y RSNCOSZERA
ER
EQ T ACA ARY M.IS
DVUEOAN SKETIIN
HE RIADA18NDRE  FADESODLELNGOAOR
H-ONHE IZMIM M A. W ONTMOTSISEMS
NASE YES, RE.D C ALE WOW MAMSO T
D CPR THE RE ONM,VA C
ITHAST BIOTH L
D,  WENS
.EARATR W TSA AEV
O ER TNOHEDRA
HEHIERTH TF
ONOMBO ADYHEN
R. EAHAN RASUCLO IERRE LPU BRINS
EAS
AL I HS E TIN T AAR TTASTTIUMITY
ARST
NGHOKRAICD FED BL
E CCAAM C  TITTHATWAFTOGA TLEDIA
HAND CYENBLWO
.ONP'HDAR,A A24F
MSHTRRU IORITSO'S H TARORAS CO R
OPOU WA AE, R  ANAN CDIGO AC TIY
EOR M
S.EN ORERENOHED UOTPIN
O WELS AT, SIERLALSRAND/7
IITEI I I I  PAVHED ONOLUPOTLEH
AEM BMENE MON M OD
EW I FAGTS SGNNS FRO CE B I  OGN
RS ALRIEAHHI D FMEIMFU  TE NU IR
SOSF  B TT'ORREPY  KBALOESRAPP
IES S DVN  AS
IRESS T ON
EG  TA BT
UN LEGE ME T
UD IGES
HTE O S.REM,REURRILHECOOMITCLRF
YE
NOSE LT
OSNTSMTAHA CBE M AIBHEF TH TIMRA
UNF
FWIOCA
SLDEA
VE BHELREID PE'SIN  A ROEATO
OWN
STON ITANERTE WELIRIDNDLETHEHAE
AN
IE
,E TAN
CAOUUS.OV W CRELIEOAR HD S ZEPRE
GSCOIODVE WOUEBAN DL TET D METND
STAN ALO ITAR
FDA
NEM AOR ATR
MBSA MNTIT COLEIDTHLY VI ELHI T
O.PLODEAROCEGYN DRO
NGILNDE CS AUMINNCILIO
H LEADDLEET C
GECCHHEILONLIY BY.AD WICERLNG R
D L M CSE  R
NAHARETELALR SMET PEWHAS
ATAT W PTE, OU A